er war zwischen den hessischen kommunen
hünstetten und idstein verläuft die
landesstraße 32 77 ende vergangenen
jahres wird die wichtige verbindung
saniert sie hat es bitter nötig neue
asphalt und die bankette werden
ordentlich befestigt kosten stolze
140000 euro
doch es gibt einen ganz gewaltigen haken
mittendrin hört die erneuerte fahrbahn
plötzlich auf ab hier geht es holprig
weiter wie eh und je
für viele bürger eine geschichte aus dem
tollhaus
ja normal denkender mensch kann es gar
nicht kapieren dass man vor den
schlimmsten schlaglöcher da einfach
aufhört finde ich einen ziemlich großen
quatsch auf gut deutsch gesagt knorz
weil der sache angefangen wird aber
nicht ordnungsgemäß fertig gestellt wird
die l 32 77 sieht ziemlich mitgenommen
aus
doch vergangenes jahr wird es noch
schlimmer der grund weil eine nahe
gelegene bundesstraße saniert werden
muss dient die landesstraße als
umleitung der zusätzliche verkehr macht
die fahrbahn noch kaputter als sie eh
schon ist
deshalb übernimmt der bund die
sanierungskosten aber nur für gerade mal
300 meter wegen der umleitung sei hier
der zustand der straße am schlimmsten
heißt es für den rest der rumpel strecke
gibt es kein geld auch nicht vom land
hessen dabei sind die straßenschäden so
gravierend dass davor gewarnt werden
muss
der zuständige landesbetrieb hessen
mobil teilt uns schriftlich mit es war
nicht möglich den weiteren teil der l 32
77 mit mitteln des landes zu sanieren da
dieser abschnitt nicht in der
sanierungsoffensive enthalten ist
es gibt in hessen andere
streckenabschnitte wie eine höhere
priorität genießen sanierungsarbeiten
mittendrin zu stoppen auf die idee muss
man erstmal kommen in hünstetten sind
die menschen bedient ist eine
katastrophe
die maschinen waren ja vor ort man hat
einfach dieses kleine stück nur machen
lösen wäre der wert in ordnung gewesen
ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen ich
finde es sehr enttäuschend dass die
straße nicht komplett saniert worden ist
es muss scheinbar immer etwas passieren
dass ein bus darunter rutsche oder
menschen zu schaden
wenn man sie jetzt in einem zweiten
schritt komplett fertig macht die straße
muss man wieder eine
baustelleneinrichtung bezahlen diese
gefahr droht erst mal nicht denn die
hessische sanierungsoffensive macht auch
zukünftig einen weiten bogen um die
marode landesstraße die menschen im
rheingau taunus kreis werden sich weiter
mit der ungeliebten buckelpiste
herumschlagen müssen bis ins jahr 2022
mindestens